yo i'm tom cruise
[Music]
yeah baby tom cruise is nuts the way
that he moves when he is doing those
stunts is incredible did you know that
there are only two people in the whole
world who have to have their own
insurance policy because they're too
expensive to ensure jackie chan tom
cruise i propose we do three we do three
things okay we do a running challenge we
do a jumping challenge and we do a
cornering challenge the winner of this
gets to wear the tom cruise jacket a
museum would be built one day oh all of
the tom cruise running sequences where
people in 20 years go like no this is
tom cruise from mission impossible too
and they're like
and then they go like to the next one
it's like and this is
yeah it's
was that tom cruise follow me and then
like you go to the next room well i am
already wearing a medium-sized black
t-shirt so i am already most like tom
cruise yeah i think tom cruise reads
those scripts before he shows up on set
he is the script
he says it differently than it's written
the script is wrong
the first challenge and the most
essential one that's so important to
being tom cruise is the running
challenge as you've probably seen in the
movies he runs incredibly well is his
efficiency is at an all-time high for
humanity his back is perfectly straight
he's on the phone cool and collectively
he's relaying information well there's
chaos all around him it doesn't matter
he will get you the message he will get
to where he's going he runs into people
he pushes them out of the way
all while being calm cool and collected
tom cruise would have never stopped that
take so you did good thank you oh i'm
not i'm not in the zone yet just you
wait as soon as i cross the finish line
tom
[Music]
and action
[Music]
[Music]
that was pretty good that was pretty
good you got here so fast look at that
dude all i heard was my name is tom
cruise
yeah that's pretty good that's a very
straight back
good slicing of the arm
now he's kind of getting a little wobble
in there a little while probably just
like direct i need to see more teeth
yeah
he has an excellent teeth
thomas cruz never runs thomas cruz in
slow motion in slow motion thomas cruz
mappather iv never runs in slow motion
three two one action
what is your real name
[Music]
smile all the way through showing the
teeth straight back running spin dodge
around clint i think it worked well
there were some things you did right
things you did wrong you forgot to say
code name tom cruise when i asked you
the first question so i don't even know
if you're actually tom cruise or not
what did you not pan over and catch my
brilliant move how was the construction
worker hit i was focused on the next
question so it wasn't good i mean i
didn't throw the papers you didn't throw
the papers no you did one job i know
well
you did one job son what
throw the paper stuff i was expecting
you to be way over here all right
you or me buddy i'll go
what's the phone action what is your
real
name of all time
[Music]
wait finish it finish it
is
[Laughter]
my cruise pouch oh god here back's not
super straight back yeah it's okay the
chin is tilting down a little forward he
ran cross country did i keep the face up
no friend did you
gut elbow gun
the phone dropped
i'm just i'm glad you finished it dude
congratulations on finishing that that
is thank you dude it was just like all
of a sudden i was not holding my phone
my glasses were gone all right let's do
it after all this talk about tom cruise
i think it's time
the real prospects to rise to form in
three two one go
aj
what do your parents do
[Music]
show me the footage show me the money
what do you guys think i think the
choice is clear we are going to pick
who's gonna be eliminated three two one
say it yeah three two one right nico
i i part of me kind of wanted to do the
next challenge
which is a perfect segue to tell you
about the next challenge and that is
jumping
how many arm rotations can you complete
and how far can you jump
jump and fly
yeah
i got my left leg tucked when it landed
had that going for me
count them up
one
two
three
three all right that's a pretty good
distance
my strategy focus all on the arms go
[Music]
dang i didn't get any arm rotations
jake beat me
so jake got the distance i got the
chickens but i don't know if i have the
rotos oh yeah six inch
oh that's pretty good three you got
three arm rotations it wasn't bad that
wasn't bad those three arms yeah
two and a half yeah on the left all
right we'll see what clint has and i'm
not going to worry about the landing i'm
just going to rotate until i crash like
that's what's going on
[Music]
[Music]
me clint jake i didn't see the arms i
was just looking oh my lord and i felt
the arms the arms were in dude
one two oh the arm rotation was good
yeah that was really salty all around
the arm rotation was solid you're in
you're next round definitely
all right um i i vote for nico staying
in
wow
wow wow what wow i'm honored but you
know what to be honest
i would have voted for jake to uh stay
in
but that's cool wait are you just voting
for who you think you can beat in the
final yeah you're not voting for who you
think you can be that's why i didn't
want to vote alone
the final round is cornering he goes
around a corner when he goes around that
corner he is at the most ridiculous
angle you've ever seen it is so
beautiful how straight his body is well
being so far over two boys are gonna run
around the corner we're gonna put the
red in a static position we're gonna put
a line of running that they cannot cross
we're going to record the same frame of
each of them running from the same
static position we're going to take it
into the studio and we're going to
examine it in post to see who has a
straighter body and who is further down
on the angle
nico's putting on different shoes for
the finale tom cruise doesn't prepare
for anything tom cruise acts he's in the
moment dude he just is
i'd say just instant disqualification
this shirt is staying and no one's
unsucking this tree
one
run
i can't tell who the winner is from this
we're gonna have to go to video review
there can only be one tom cruise
at least in this office
and we're about to find out who we've
got our footage pulled up we've got the
protractors
on the footage to see
the angle of the lean
that is pretty good that's that's why
i'm hitting max lean at the end yeah i
mean
oh it looks that way that's pretty ooh
look at that that's a look at that
that's some good dude that's a that's a
that's a silhouette right here
boy
you can see you can tell i'm like great
my head is
in the future i think what we could do
is actually get like um one of those
levels for an iphone start screen
recording it and put it on the chest now
and then you run as your screen
recording the level on your phone
and
i think we get to set this up right
right here so when we're running we can
see like being so good oh man i feel
like it's almost worth getting hyper
precise with this
we need you to be the judge which one
embodies tom cruise
you can't tell from this
wow
let's see that again
let's see that again
it's a clear choice this spot i know my
vote just like oscillating i know my
vote
let's say it at the same time one glitco
did you do your water breathing
challenge yet oh whoever can hold the
breath the longest whoever can hold
their breath the longest i don't know if
you want to take that challenge okay i
practiced i have practiced he goes
pretty good one winner only one winner
is my challenge
i challenge you the winner emerges
victorious with the jacket
normally in underwater sequences people
hold their breath for 10 seconds 15
seconds max i'll count down fully from
the head
[Music]
you have to over train for a sequence
three
two
one
go
health silence
30 seconds
45 seconds
[Music]
one minute
[Music]
[Music]
90 seconds
two minutes
maybe i'll record your face
two minutes 30 seconds
255
three minutes
people just broke their own personal
records
[Music]
[Music]
three thirty
wow
we're doing up to six and a half minute
breath holds with nico as the winner of
my hair oh my
in the middle of it i was just like i
was like wait a second how do we know if
they're still playing you know they
passed out
this shirt is staying and no one's on
talking this train clinton you stand up
for me
yeah can you stand up for me
[Music]
oh my god all right can you put your
hands up
oh
wow
the guys over at rocket jump just
released the second season of one of
their weirdest shows i've ever seen it's
really cool it's called anime crimes
division why should you check it out
well it's definitely one of their bigger
projects it's really funny if you are
into anime or that whole world like we
are you should check it out i think
you'll get a huge kick out of it also i
had the pleasure of having a little bit
of a cameo in there that's right i had
to memorize lines i'm just happy to help
those guys out anytime they need it
because it's really fun making videos
with them check it out it's on rocket
jump thanks
[Music]
dad
that was a smooth landing